Serve traditions,
serve the father a psychologically
speaking,
support the tradition because you live
on it there in the old Mesopotamian
story,
um,
the Enuma Elish,
which you can,
which you can read about if you're
interested in the original gods who are
really badly behaved.
They're like two year olds.
In fact,
there are a lot like two year olds,
they kill the primordial God absolute
who's the Patriarchal God to kill them
and try to live on his corpse.
Well,
that's what we all do,
right?
Because we live on a corpse of our
ancestors.
You could say we live in the Corpus of
our culture.
It's dead and that's not a great place
to live.
So you have to keep reinventing it.
So the damn thing you know,
stays active and awake.
You stay on the carbs for too long and
then the devil of or the demon of chaos
comes back.
And that's what happens in the
Mesopotamian story.
It's like don't be thinking that you can
stay on the core of your ancestors for
too long without contributing to the
revivification of the system because the
chaos that all of that holds,
that,
that all of that holds,
that Bay will definitely come and visit
you and you'll see that in stories like
a hobbit.
You know hobbits,
they're nice,
they like to eat,
they're kind of fat,
they're short,
they're not very bright.
You know there are hubris stick.
They have no idea what's out there in
the broader world.
They're protected.
If you remember by the striders who are
the sons of great kings who looked like
tramps,
they have nothing but contempt for them.
They patrol the borders and keep the
bloody hobbits safe,
but they're out there in the periphery.
All Hell is brewing and chaos is,
is,
is generating,
informing,
and that's an archetypal story and
that's why people liked that story so
much because that's exactly right.
Like we're the hobbits and there are,
we are protected from chaos by the
spirits of our dead ancestors and we're
too damn stupid to know it and we think,
oh well we don't need them anymore.
And that to me,
that's postmodernism.
That's what the bloody universities are
doing with the humanities to absolutely
appalling and we will pay for it.
So unless we wake up and hopefully we'll
wake up because that would be better
than paying for it.
Even though being awake is rather
painful.